I would differentiate Israel then I know
other places
Syria Egypt in other places the press is
under control of the government and
therefore not free and therefore its
ability to be aggressive and critical
with the government is very very limited
in Israel I work for the largest Israeli
daily during Friday our Sunday we have
something like 80% of the readership a
million copies which is for a country
for 7 million people it's quite a lot
basically everybody reads this paper so
it's quite effective it's wide effective
in the sent in the in the in the sense
that once you publish a big scoop a big
revelation everybody knows about it
everybody reads everybody so at least
the follow-ups in the electronic media
and it has major effect though in some
of the cases because Israel is yet a
very young country where its executive
branch still don't understand the real
meaning of Freedom of Information the
real meaning of obeying the law having
obeying the the chain of command and the
hierarchy and basically understanding
that the executive branch tea in the
government offices and in and services
and agencies serve the public and not
the other way around some of the
revelations that I published about
corruption in the government served me
as a lesson to be far modest with my
abilities and and power and impact
because it was published everybody know
that something horrendous is going on in
I don't know Mossad or the government
health office or somewhere else but
nothing changed because if someone like
this would have been published in United
States the the person involved next day
would be either fired or resigning and
would be ashamed to show his face in the
street in Israel functioning in the
state of war and still not grasping the
the real meaning of of a democracy in
that sense
and obeying the law still accept the
fact that corrupted people are part of
the government and in a sense diminish
the power or the effect of the press
you